today we are putting the saying grandma
knows best
to the test with using dating apps
um please welcome her beautiful
granddaughter ashley
and this really awesome cool grandmother
joy hi
[Applause]
hi ladies hello joy
no i was curious yes what do you think
about the world of dating apps i think
it's probably better
now makes it easier much easier than
what
i was a youngster um
much more with the apps yeah
ashley i'd love to know as a modern
woman
how is your experience on dating apps
it's very hit or miss
um but it's hard because you can't
really judge i mean
you get the pictures you see the prompts
on app but you can't really tell who
they are
so it's like you're going in blind on
that first date rather than like going
to a bar
and just meeting them you get to gauge
the personality and for me
it's all about personality and rather
than look so
i'm with you ashley it is not the looks
it is all about the personality
100 i mean what i've been doing now is
actually doing like a little phone
screen before
meeting them in person so it's we'll
connect on the app and then we'll have a
facetime
sort of meet and greet and if we vibe
through facetime
then we'll kind of plan the next step
do you think you can tell really quickly
on facetime is it like has it been a
good editing process
it's interesting because i had a really
great facetime date a week ago or two
weeks ago
and um we met in person and
the connection wasn't there i went on a
date with someone
fairly recently first date was like out
of a movie it was
perfection and then the second date he
was a total grump and a bad mood and i
was like
what that's the thing inconsistent on
date two you have that
i mean what come on what do you do in
that situation i have no
idea i have no clue do you cut them out
i had a date with what
1960 i mean it's been a long time so
i wouldn't know you're asking the wrong
one and yet
you are basically conducting joy's i
sure am and good luck
i love it i know nothing now let me rule
your dating life
um what do you look for
in a man for ashley to all dark handsome
well it doesn't have to be tall dark in
hand it's just nice looking gives a nice
appearance good personality
um likes to go and do
have fun all right well we're gonna try
to find ashley a great date
let's see if we have any luck here okay
before we start
we're gonna kick it old school and go
like old dating game show with you
and will you please put on this
blindfold
and um leave everything up to your
grandmother
here we go this is this is child okay
so before the show a joy happened to
swipe
right on these three guys
using apps like tinder and here they are
now we'd love to welcome maxwell
brody and matthew hello
gentlemen um
okay can you each introduce yourself
starting with maxwell
hi um my name is maxwell 28 years old
originally from cincinnati living in new
york i work in sales
at the moment sales yeah i also i have
like
aspirations to be a writer but you got
to pay the bills i like that
i understand that completely do you
write
um in your free time maxwell yeah yeah
excellent right as long as you're doing
that's like right
like personal blog type things and i
write screenplays
okay all right so that's very cool okay
um
thank you maxwell okay brody hi how are
you
hey drew hi joy hi ashley i am 26 years
old
i live in new york city i am a digital
account manager
by day again to pay the bills um but i
also do
private chefing at night which is
something i'm super passionate about
and uh yeah i'm ex really excited to be
here
that is awesome thank you so much brody
i really appreciate that um okay and
matthew
who are you can you tell us a little
something about yourself
hi um i'm matthew um i live in uh
new jersey i'm born and raised i live in
downtown jersey city
and uh i'm a financial analyst and um
i as a hobby i paint as you can see
behind me is uh
i think i did nice yeah uh you know i'm
just fun loving guy
i love your painting buddy very pretty
thank you
um okay for the first round each guy is
gonna answer
um the question i have and then they're
gonna answer the question that joy has
so
my question to maxwell is what is your
ideal first
date if you can be elaborate um for me
i you know i haven't been out a ton
lately so i'm thinking multi-part
usually i like to
get my date involved in planning but i
want to
start off going to the whip museum for a
couple hours and then
maybe go to some rooftops in the uh in
the me packing district
and then facetime grandma and see if she
wants to meet us for dinner
oh stop it i love that face from you
yes oh very smart maxwell very smart
okay um now uh matthew if you don't mind
um
answering the same question what would
be an ideal first date for you
uh so um the first ideal first day would
probably be like grab some coffee i used
to
be a barista as a side job during
college so that's a big thing for me
i definitely love to walk around the
city you know a big museum guy love
plants so like
definitely like maybe even see a
botanical garden and end off with like a
nice dinner and drinks
botanical garden dinner drinks
okay that sounds good okay you guys are
gonna have to work for it today
joy is no nonsense okay
rhodey um and she has your best interest
ashley don't forget that that's right
brody um you're next will you please
tell us what your ideal first date would
be
of course well with joy's permission um
ashley and i would go to a nice
bottomless
brunch i love italian food i love all
types of food
um i think bottomless brunch we can have
a few cocktails have some nice meals
really get to know each other
on kind of that deeper level and then i
do
love going to museums either the moma
the whitney
um because i'm very into art and
different cultures
and i mean if we're able to hit it off
ashley and i
looking at different pieces of art
chatting about different cultures
um i think that's an a a plus date um
sounds good
at museums bottomless brunch sounds
terrific
okay great joy based on these answers
which two guys do you think
could move on to the next round may i
ask
you can ask and i'll tell you uh matthew
maxwell okay um matthew and maxwell
if you don't mind coming back after
commercial and joining us brody
um joy has made her decision i'm totally
pinning this on her i'm like it's all
joy she she gave you the old no i'm just
kidding
um if it's okay we are gonna move on
without you but we can't thank you
enough for participating today
and we wish you the best out there in
the romance department and thank you so
much for being on the show
thank you so much for the opportunity
you